when did masculinity become something
bad
as i sit here with ripped jeans and my
legs crossed
maybe when we all when all those men
decided that we would accept that
characterization of it
i never accepted it i mean like i don't
i remember
growing up right and i think i saw it
like play out in movies like i remember
growing up
and i remember seeing like tv too from
my three sons and father knows best to
um
dude well to what are the three every
father being a buffoon
yeah so i'm i'm literally watching
movies and i'm like okay bruce willis is
saving the day
right and then like 90s bruce willis is
still saving the day
and then it's 2000's i'm like do we have
nobody new here is bruce willis still
the only [ __ ] man
left saving the god damn day like that
we just ran out of young uh i guess
masculine men that were going to be the
heroes and then all of a sudden like
these like michael sarah types he could
be a sweet guy but he's playing like
this imp
guy you know it was just being like
walked around on a leash by his girl and
everything yeah good got to be good got
to be synonymous with harmless
i i but i don't understand it because i
don't think that like
i don't think that you can make that a
trend
i can't speak on behalf of chicks but i
don't think that you can like
make chicks like beta males
i i don't think that exists right like
don't we like what we like
i mean maybe an outfit can change maybe
we like certain genes and other people
like skirts but
at the end of the day i think there's
gonna be certain characteristics of the
opposite sex that we're gonna be drawn
to biologically well you know the
one of the ones you already discussed is
competence
anybody with any sense is going to
prefer competence unless they want
someone who's emasculated and is
completely powerless and because then
they don't have to be afraid of them
in some sense i mean they should be more
afraid of them really but
you know when you confuse competence
with power
then you punish competence and maybe
then you become attracted to
weakness because it's not authoritarian
it doesn't look like tyranny but it's
it's that's only because competence and
power are confused in your mind
competence and power yeah there's this
thing with power
yeah that's for sure it's on you know
there's this claim that
all of our institutions are based on
power it's like no they're not
only when they're corrupt is that true
has anybody that you've studied
throughout history
managed to obtain a significant amount
of power
and done the right thing with it
well i think most of our institutions
that function reasonably well
do do that reasonably well or had
you know i mean we're all flawed but
there's a huge difference between joseph
stalin and franklin roosevelt
yeah a little bit yeah so i mean if you
look look at
look at the democratic west all things
considered yeah
the leadership has been okay okay to
good
especially compared to absolutely
catastrophically horrible which is the
alternative yeah
yeah is it so when we we've
we don't give our functional
institutions the benefit of the doubt
and
that doesn't mean they shouldn't be
subject to criticism but the idea that
they're predicated on arbitrary power
and that's their essential nature that's
appalling i wasn't being critical of the
institutions
no no i know okay yeah i'm just curious
about like
i'm just curious about like a human's
relationship well you have a car
yeah does it work yeah how often
um currently every time i use it
so like if you use it a thousand times
how many times doesn't it work
uh zero out of a thousand a car right
you said car yeah a car
okay okay yeah okay well that
institution is doing pretty well
yeah because i have a 99.9 percent
success rate i'm not saying about flying
have you crashed yet when you flew i
mean i think you're jinxing me but
no uh no and and they're so safe it's
just beyond comprehension
yeah no i agree with you i'm not i'm not
upset like institutions in that i'm
talking about like
a human being that is compelled to power
like i understand certain people being
compelled to greatness
that's really cool you see it in
athletes and what's the difference
what's the difference
i think there is your concern i think
there is a difference because i think
like once somebody accesses power they
don't necessarily need to be more great
right they'll just do whatever they can
to continue to have that power
where there are people what do they do
this is a good thing to differentiate
you made this case
greatness versus power okay okay let's
take it apart okay
so you just said there's something
arbitrary about power
yeah i think i think there's something i
think there's something about people who
desire
power instead of greatness and i think
that power comes with greatness
but if you're if your desire is power i
think there is something dangerous there
because you're willing to do whatever it
is to maintain that power
where it's the mimicry of greatness it's
the mimicry of greatness
greatness deserves power because you
want the powerful to be great
to be powerful why wouldn't you oh
that's why we exalt these people that we
believe are great
we want them to have it they've earned
it well who else would you want to lead
you
i mean if they're good at doing
something why wouldn't you put them in
the front
you want to be led with some by someone
who isn't great i mean you think of all
the
all the times we spent as tribal hunters
who do you put in charge
the best hunter perhaps the best hunter
who's also the most generous
yeah exactly you want the guy that's
going to share that yeah right
that would make him a great hunter too
great because over time he would have
people in his hunting party
you want great you want productivity and
generosity so how do we business
how do we discern between people who are
mimicking
power greatness for power and greatness
that's a great question by paying
careful attention by listening and by
talking about it that's the purpose of
free speech that's the purpose of
political attention
because you want the great but it can be
mimicked by
it's mimicked by psychopaths who will
use power but that doesn't mean that
power is the basis of our
of our hierarchical human relationships
that's only the case when they've gone
badly wrong
what do you mean by that i mean well
when when a society is corrupt then the
powerful rule
when a society isn't corrupt then the
great have authority
that's not the same thing and confusing
those
you asked why why the beta male is now
this object of attention it's because
we've confused great and powerful
and now we're so afraid of power that
we're willing to dispense with greatness
entirely
or even to question whether it exists
that's the attack on the meritocracy
there's no meritocracy oh there's no
greatness and no one who has a position
deserves it there's no difference in
talent
that doesn't mean our institutions are
pure and that everyone with talent is
rewarded
yes but but because no institution is
pure and no selection method is 100
accurate but you made this distinction
between great
greatness and power yes so pursue it
okay how do you know someone's great
as far as you're concerned how do i know
someone is great i have great admiration
for the skills okay
you admire them for the skill yeah well
that's weird that see that's an
interesting thing because we have this
instinct of admiration it's like you see
someone and you admire them yeah it's
like
why you want to be like them yeah that's
imitation right that's the instinct of
imitation yeah
and because we can identify what's great
because it would be better to be great
than the way we are so when we see it
you think oh man
yeah i really admire that and maybe
you're mad about that because you're
so unlike that and it's judgmental and
makes you annoyed
right but fundamentally you think i'd
like to be like that so there's one
admiration you admire what's great if
you have any sense
yeah okay and that happens spontaneously
especially in a domain that you value
yes exactly the more i value the mo the
domain the more
god i can't speak the more um yeah the
the more adversarial admiration
absolutely i do not
admire power i i don't even care about
people who are powerful if they don't
have something that i admire some sort
of skill set that i care about
the only thing that's nice is like the
ease of power you can open up doors
easier
you know but i'm way more impressed by
like a powerful
person that actually has a skill i
didn't even know about
like that to me makes me go oh cool that
oh maybe that's why he got there
but just holding the position isn't
admirable to me
in any way at all